un bail
[Musique]
ja
édiles chéri agents de sécurité gardes
du corps ps j'ai commencé à temps que
fortis avant le diable quand j'ai été
agent de sécurité du magasin puis quand
j'ai commencé vraiment coûté bon si le
que je les cherche un peu plus de tout
défense des bleus c'est une version pour
apprécier faille sa garde
je reviens à eau je finis avec la fin
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer georges
st-pierre à l'arrière de brocade c'est
un jour mon entraîneur me demandiez dit
qui va se passer avec georges
aujourd'hui a été un peu stressant pour
moi mais c'est super bien passé
[Musique]
quand que jose a commencé à être le plus
en plus populaire sa gérante à l'époque
elle m'a approché et m'a demandé a dit
est-ce que ça t'intéresserait de ce
genre dans
ces déplacements à l'extérieur
[Applaudissements]
disons que j'ai pris la place de mauvais
garçons autour de jose vicente des gens
qu'on voit venir être proche qui est
approché dont je m main dessus qu'il
faudra dit mme aubry zimbra et morizet
doper les poursuites s'enchaînent je
suis encore de gym quand j'entends ce
calme didier drogba
je suis directeur d'une entreprise de
sécurité qu'ils ont sécurisé
mais environ 250 employés
si un jour quelqu'un voudrait de gardes
du corps je conseille à tout le monde
d'être portés dans un bas parce que on
voit toutes sortes de clients pour toute
demande
[Musique]
l'alcool qui rentrent en cause de tout
ça des menaces on voit des armes à feu
les armes blanches la première fois
qu'on entend un coup de feu et web ça
fait réfléchir
un garde temps qui disparaît je crois
que si nous
un peu ensemble si savoir comment
contrôler sa part je pense pas que
quelqu'un puisse faire ce métier deux
silos pour un sens d'observation
commençant c'est qu'ils adaptent en
prévenir un danger commun
sa voix était à venir discuter avec les
gens pour désamorcer une situation
olivier avec la force du rectum
les quartiers défavorisés et jamais
jamais et
renier
les racines
fi des gens que j'ai connus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]